[Musique]
madame la conseillère d'État cherane
monsieur le vice-président du Grand
Conseil Monsieur le Consul général
Monsieur le Maire de la Ville de
Genève merci vous aurez remarqué que
j'ai pris la précaution de mettre un
point d'interrogation don je ne suis pas
sûr que je vais vous donner une réponse
euh je vais probablement pour partie de
cet exposé vous détailler la question
euh du reste il y a une partie des pays
pour lesquels on pourrait barrer Suisse
et en mettre d'autres euh parce que vous
allez voir que nous sommes dans un dans
dans dans une dans un contexte euh qui
englobe un certain nombre de pays alors
voilà d'abord j'ai une bonne nouvelle
euh vous savez qu'actuellement euh un
certain nombre de pays ont décidé
d'aller vers la neutralité carbone et le
recours à 100 % d'énergie renouvelable
alors ma très bonne nouvelle c'est que
ça ne pose aucun problème de faire ça
euh puisque puisque là vous voyez une
image d'un monde où nous étions neutr en
carbone et 100 % énergie renouvelable
donc ça ne pose absolument aucun
problème d'être 100 % et en fait la
question qu'il faut se poser vous savez
c'est beaucoup de gens ont dit ça je
crois Churchill l'a dit entre autres
personnes que le plus loin vous regardez
dans le passé le mieux vous comprenez
l'avenir et donc là la question c'est si
ce monde était si merveilleux que ça 100
% renouvelable et neutr en carbone
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'est enququiné à
le carboné alors que maintenant il
faudrait le décarboner il faut quand
même être un peu pervers pour commencer
par faire quelque chose qui est l'exacte
inverse de ce que vous êtes censé faire
donc là vous voyez ce monde 100 %
renouvelable vous avez des transports
terrestres parfaitement renouvelables
les chevaux parfaitement renouvelés dans
les boucheries chevalines à l'époque du
reste mangeant de l'herbe
renouvelable vous avez des transports en
bois renouvelable sur une rivière
renouvelable faisant tourner des moulins
à eau renouvelable euh vous avez
beaucoup de Moulins encore de vestiges
de vieux moulin encore en Suisse comme
en France il y avait quelque part sur
ces collines un moulin utilisant du vent
renouvelable on utilisait du bois
renouvelable et cetera enfin tout était
renouvelable dans le meilleur des mondes
donc la bonne question c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en est sorti car nous en
sommes sortis vous avez ici une courbe
qui vous donne pour le monde dans son
ensemble alors j'ai pas des statistiques
sur séries aussi longes pour la Suisse
malheureusement ni pour la France mais
enfin pour le monde ça ira bien pour le
moment qui vous donne la part des
énergies renouvelables en verre la part
des énergies fossiles en moutarde et
puis tout en bas là rien que pour
énerver le mer la part de l'énergie
nucléaire voilà mais il a raison c'est
pas vu vu vu le truc que ça représente
en bas à droite là c'est pas la peine de
s'écharper là-dessus pour le moment euh
dans dans le monde et ce que vous voyez
c'est que le siècle et demi qui vient de
s'écouler c'est manifestement un
basculement massif en défaveur des
énergies renouvelables et en faveur des
énergies fossiles donc la bonne question
encore une fois c'est est-ce que nous
étions tous des crétins patentés et on a
fait ça juste pour le plaisir d'être
malfaisant ùou est-ce qu'il y avait une
très bonne raison à ce que nous ayons
fait ça alors en fait il y a plusieurs
très bonnes raisons à ce que nous ayons
fait ça et qui vont peut-être faire écho
aux dernières recherches qui viennent de
nous être présenté qui est que les
hommes et les femmes sont certes des
esprits supérieurs dignes de recevoir
des prix dans des universités
prestigieuses de temps en temps mais
nous sommes aussi des animaux gouvernés
par nos sens et nos sens nous rendent en
particulier
paresseux
accumulatif et ayant envie de monter
dans l'échelle sociale comme énormément
d'autres mammifères alors énormément de
mammifères sont paresseux pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont paresseux ça veut
dire queils vont chercher à maximiser ou
à économiser le plus longtemps possible
leur énergie corporelle des fois que
celle-ci soi nécessaire pour échapper à
un prédateur ou attraper une proie donc
en fait nous sommes biologiquement
quelque part conditionnés pour essayer
toujours de minimiser les efforts que
nous allons faire pour obtenir les
efforts corporels que nous allons faire
pour obtenir un résultat donné nous
sommes accumulatifs depuis que nous
avons sédentariser les civilisations
humaines il y a 10000 ans et bien nous
avons également tendance à faire des
réserves d'énergie extra corpor Corelle
vous connaissez tous la fable de la
cigale et de la fourmi et dans cette
affaire manifestement c'est la fourmi
qui a le beau rôle c'est-à-dire celle
qui accumule parce que comme ça on ne
sait jamais he ça permet de faire face
au mauvais jour et enfin nous sommes des
animaux sociaux et comme tous les
animaux sociaux nous avons besoin de
code au sein des groupes auxquels nous
appartenons et une des choses que nous
aimons faire parce que nous sommes des
animaux sociaux c'est d'essayer d'avoir
la plus haute place possible dans la
hiérarchie du reste si on essayait pas
il y aurait pas d'étudiant à
l'université de jeève euh voilà parce
que c'est la première chose qui motive
les gens qui rentrent ici c'est de
monter dans la hiérarchie sociale c'est
bien la preuve que c'est une c'est une
motivation puissante et bien c'est à
cause de ces trait de comportement
biologiques que nous avons basculé dans
les énergies fossiles qui permettent de
faire avec considérablement moins
d'efforts ce que nous devions faire
avant avec beaucoup de sueur et beaucoup
d'effort du temps des énergies
renouvelables alors je vais vous donner
un exemple je ne sais pas si ici il y a
qui que ce soit qui est déjà monté de
Cère jusqu'en haut du vaissorn dans la
journée s'il y a une personne qui a déjà
fait ça je veux bien voir la main se
lever pas sûr que non voilà donc ah vous
avez déjà fait ça dans la journée bravo
je
m'incline donc imaginons que vous
fassiez 4000 m de dénivl dans la journée
en montant le poids de votre propre
corps plus un petit sac quand vous allez
faire ça en général avec vos jambes
parce que si vous avez fait ça en
hélicoptère ça vaut pas et bien vos
jambes on fournit une puissance une
énergie mécanique pardon de l'ordre de 1
kWh pour ceux à qui ça rappelle quelque
chose c'est e é= MGH c'est-à-dire que
vous avez votre masse
qui lutte contre le champ gravitationnel
en ayant monté 4000 m vous pourrez faire
le calcul vous verrez ça fait 1 kWh
imaginons que vous fassiez ça en 10h je
si vous l'avez fait en 10h ou un peu
plus un peu plus bon alors vous êtes
même pas arrivé au 100 W mais si vous
faites ça en 10h ça ve dire non mais en
fait vous avez fourni beaucoup plus d'un
kWh parce que d'abord il faut marcher
dans la neige et puis vous avez le
centre de gravité qui fait pas juste une
enfin bon bref donc euh mais si si vous
faites ça à vélo on va dire sans
absolument aucune bosse et cetera ça va
vous faire à peu près 100 W depuis
puissance moyenne sur une journée
d'efforts de cette nature donc vous
voyez un être humain au travail un être
humain est parfaitement renouvelable euh
et bien est capable de dégager une
puissance d'à peu près 100 W avec ses
jambes sur une journée de dur
labeur imaginons que euh là vous soyez
dans les travaux public et non pas au
sommet du weissorne et bien et que vous
décaissiez alors là donc on est revenu à
Genève et dans la voirie et qu'on
décaisse 6 m CUB c'est-à-dire 15 tonnes
de terre dans la journée à ce moment
l'effort mécanique que vous allez
fournir se monte à 0,05 kWh ou c'est
vraiment pas beaucoup et euh si vous
faites cet effort sur 5 he vos bras et
un peu mouche tout de votre dos du reste
ont fournit une puissance moyenne de
l'ordre de 10 W donc retenez à partir de
ces exemples que un être humain au
travail de force il est capable de
développer sur quelques heures une
puissance de 10 à 100 W et si vous
regardez la quantité d'énergie mécanique
qu'il est capable de fournir non pas sur
une journée mais sur une année parce que
une fois que vous avez fait le viceor
dans la journée en général vous
recommencez pas le lendemain euh non on
est d'accord hein euh et bien vous allez
être capable de fournir avec votre corps
une énergie mécanique qui se balade
entre 10 et 100 kWh sur une annéein
retenez ces deux ordres de grandeur
maintenant on va prendre un litre
d'essence qui coûte le prix
scandaleusement élevé de 2 francs en
Suisse plus ou moins quelque chose et en
ce moment le prix scandaleusement élevé
de 2 € en France plus ou moins quelque
chose dans un lre d'essence vous avez à
peu près 10 kWh d'énergie thermique en
la faisant brûler et selon l'ingénieur
qui aura fait la voiture dans Je
plaisente selon le régime moteur vous
aurez entre 2 et 4 kWh d'énergie
mécanique en sortie du moteur d'accord
ce qui veut dire que dans un litre
d'essence dont vous allez voir que un
français ou un Suisse consomme un
certain nombre de litres dans l'année et
bien vous avez la même capacité à
transformer l'environnement que dans 10
à 100 jours de travail de force d'un
être humain vous avez là la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes passés de la force
corporell et des énergies renouvelables
qui étaient des supplétifs pas
extrêmement puissants aux machines MU à
l'énergie fossile qui permettent de
faire le même travail dans des temps
considérablement plus courts et avec des
puissances à disposition
considérablement plus importante si on
parle l'argent et que je paye alors là
en l'occurrence c'est en France euh mon
mon travailleur au salaire minimum
admissible dans le pays je vais payer
mon kilwh d'énergie mécanique
c'est-à-dire ma capacité à transformer
l'environnement de 200 à 2000 € quand la
machine alors c'était à 1,5 € par litre
à 2 ça fait 0,5 mais peu importe me
fournit le même service pour un coût
marginal de quelques dizaines de
centimes dit autrement en passant de
l'énergie corporelle aux machines mu par
l'énergie fossile je suis capable de
diviser le coût d'une transformation
unitaire de l'environnement par quelques
centaines à quelques milliers ça a fait
le monde occidental moderne et ça a fait
la Suisse moderne la Suisse moderne sans
le pétrole n'existerait pas pas plus que
la France moderne pas plus que l'Italie
moderne pas plus que le Vietnam
d'aujourd'hui hein ça n'existerait pas
et il y aurait pas de prix la
6 Fez des
économies imaginons maintenant que je
prennent un esclave c'est tout à fait
immoral et bien l'esclave il va quand
même falloir dépenser de l'argent pour
aller le chercher ou l'acheter à
quelqu'un qui a fait ça pour vous
l'empêcher de vous igouiller comme dans
Django le nourrir le vêtir et cetera et
bien vous vous rendez compte que si vous
additionner tous ces coups encore une
fois c'est parfaitement immoral il
n'empêche vous allez quand même arriver
à un coup économique de la possession
d'un esclave qui est 10 à 100 fois
supérieur à celui d'une machine qui n'a
strictement rien contre sa condition
d'esclave et qui jusqu'à une période
très récente n'était absolument pas vu
comme une détention immorale ça commence
à changer un peu maintenant avec les
gros 44 mais jusqu'à récemment c'était
pas vu comme une détention
immorale vous avez donc là l'explication
pour laquelle en Suisse comme ailleurs
nous sommes passés des énergies
renouvelables fa l'énergie corporelle
aux énergies fossiles mais j'aurais pu
vous faire le même le même tableau avec
les les les énergie renouvelable de
telle sorte qu'aujourd'hui la totalité
de nos auxiliaires mécaniques sont
devenus surpuissants comparé à notre
propre corps donc je le redis la
puissance moyenne des jambes de votre
mère 100 W c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut
le rélire mais quand même ça en
impose maintenant on va prendre un
mixeur à soupe vous avez déjà mixé de la
soupe après descendu du veissor vous
avez mixé de la soupe nécessairement et
bien la puissance du premier mixeur à
soupe venu un petit truc 50 € 50 francs
pardon que vous achetez et cetera quatre
fois votre mire c'est-à-dire que quand
vous appuyez sur le mixeur à soupe vous
avez quatre mèes qui sortent du mixeur à
souple qui se mettent à pédaler comme
des forcenet quatre clones hein et puis
quand vous réappuyez sur le bouton
marcharê les clones rerentrent voilà les
élections sont terminées les clones
rerentrent dans le mixeur à soupe et
c'est terminé donc je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte ce tout petit truc
ridicule qui tient dans une main
développe en fait la puissance de quatre
organismes bien entraînés en train de
pédaler au moment où vous allez mixer la
la soupe après la soupe et ses crooutons
vous avez mis des miettes partout vous
passez l'aspirateur là vous avez di mè
qui sortent de l'aspirateur quand vous
appuyez sur le bouton marchear pour
faire fonctionner le ventilateur de
l'aspirateur
50 mèes sont nécessaires pour faire
fonctionner un
ascenseur alors là c'est plus le mer
puisque il s'agit de paire de bras mais
un engin de travaux public il y en a
quelques-uns en Suisse me semble-t-il
euh lui quand l'ouvrier va monter dans
la cabine de pilotage il va multiplier
la puissance de ses bras par àu près
10000 au moment où l'appel mécanique se
met en action c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui on peut terrasser
un terrain pour y construire un maen un
chalet ou une maison pavillonnaire en
une journée alors qu'avant avec des
pelles et des pioches il fallait des
semaines un camion quelques uns en
Suisse aussi euh et bien quand le
conducteur monte dans la cabine de son
camion il démultiplie la puissance de
ses jambes par 4000 donc là on est de
douau chez le maire 4000 Mair pour faire
avancer un camion alors j'ai pas les
effectifs de camion de la Suisse vous me
pardonnerez mais j'ai ceux de la France
en France vous avez 600000 camions ça
veut dire que si on voulait remplacer
les moteurs de camions par des gens
attelés devant les camions pour faire
avancer les camions il faudrait que pour
la seule flotte de camion en France je m
au travail la moitié de la population
adulte
mondiale pe faire le calcul 600000 x
4000 ça fait 2illard 4 c'est-à-dire que
vous auriez besoin de la moitié de la
population adulte mondiale rien que pour
fournir la même puissance mécanique que
les camions que nous avons en France et
même si le transit est interdit dans ce
pays il y a quand même quelques camions
qui circule sans quoi les magasins ne
seraient pas approvisionnés et vous
mourriez de faim ce qui n'est pas très
enviable prenons maintenant à lamisoire
alors vous n'avez pas de laminoire en
Suisse safur de ma part pas de lamisoire
en Suisse hein voilà vous avez quand
même des objets en acier donc ça veut
dire que les lamisoires sont ailleurs en
dehors de Suisse on y viendra tout à
l'heure quand on parlera de l'empreinte
carbone en France nous avons deux
lamisoires euh peut-être qu'une partie
de l'acier laminé en France du reste
vous en bénéficiez sinon il vient
d'ailleurs et bien chacun des laminoirs
si je devais le remplacer par des
Français tapant ou des Suisses tiens je
vais prendre des Suisses tapant sur des
tôles toute la journée avec un marteau
pour applanir les tôes et bien un seul
des deux Lamin noirs installés en France
me mobiliserait la totalité de la
population suisse donc il y aurait plus
de chercheurs il y aurait plus de
gestionnaires de fondation il y aurait
plus de recteur d'université il y aurait
plus de mer il y aurait plus de
conférencier enfin même si je suis
français il y aurait plus tout ça on
serait tous en train de taper sur des
tôes toute la journée pour remplacer
juste un des deux laminoirs que nous
avons en France et qui sert peut-être
aussi la Suisse et surans lequel vous
n'auriez pas de moyen de transport pas
de construction pas d'électroménager pas
de siège et j'en passe et des meilleurs
et pas de braguettees c'est quand même
important donc là vous avez une petite
idée de la quantité de et vous n'auriez
pas la mondialisation parce qu'il y
aurait pas les porortes conteneurs et
les vraquiers j'y viendrai un peu plus
tard donc là vous avez une petite idée
de quelques machines quelques machines
il y a des milliards de machines sur
terre qui travaill pour nous des
milliards en fait les machines que nous
avons absolument partout sur terre qui
sont en train de travailler pour nous
elles nous ont construit même si nous
nous en rendons pas compte un costume de
super-héros qui a considérablement
démultiplier la puissance de nos propres
muscles toutes ces machines fonctionnent
essentiellement à l'énergie fossile soit
directement parce qu'elles sont
alimentées par des moteur à combustion
interne ou des machines à vapeur soit
indirectement parce qu'elles sont
alimentées par de l'électricité qui
aujourd'hui dans le monde est à 60 %
fait avec des combustibles fossiles et
en fait si je regarde à l'instant où je
vous parle la puissance de la totalité
des machines qui sont en fonctionnement
dans le monde donc je prends en ce
moment tous les camions qui circulent
tous les bateaux qui circulent tous les
laminoires qui laminent de l'acier euh
tous les camions toutes les grues qui
sont en train de fonctionner toutes les
machines à filtration pour l'eau potable
toutes les toutes les machines à
dérouler les grumes de bois et cetera
enfin bon bref toutes les machines qui
fonctionnent bien évidemment en
supposant qu'elles ont leur bibin
particulière qui s'appelle des énergies
fossiles et bien à tout instant ces
machines démultipli démultiplient pardon
la puissance musculaire de l'humanité
par un facteur
200 ça revient à dire que dans un monde
dans lequel il n'y aurait pas d'énergie
fossile pour obtenir la même capacité
productive que celle que nous avons
aujourd'hui puisque ces machines
travaillent à notre place c'est elles
qui font tourner l'économie il faudrait
passer la population humaine de 8 à 1600
milliards d'individus alors déjà qu'à 8
on a quelques petits problèmes de place
bien évidemment à 1600 voilà une manière
inverse de dire ça c'est que si ces
machines n'existaient pas le PIB mondial
serait divisé par 200
loups que devient l'Université de Genève
que devient Genève que deviennent les
avocats fiscalistes de Genève et les
banques offshore j'ai rien dit dans un
monde dans lequel le PIB est divisé par
200 bien évidemment ça devient rien du
tout du reste les conférenciers et les
consultants carbon deviennent rien du
tout non plus hein donc ici vous voyez
une une une troisème manière de de de
dire la même chose c'est que dans un
monde sans machine il faudrait 200
esclaves à un terrien ordinaire pour
vivre comme il vit aujourd'hui alors
c'est 200 pour un terrien ordinaire
c'est 600 pour un Français ordinaire et
c'est malheureusement 800 pour un Suisse
ordinaire parce que vous êtes plus
riche donc vous allez consommer plus on
le verra tout à l'heure c'est pas très
écolo ici vous avez la conclusion
logique ou la conséquence logique plus
exactement de cette addiction au
combustible fossil que nous avons
développé parce que je le répète nous
sommes je le répète pardon nous sommes
paresseux accumulatif et attaché aux
objets de statut ici vous voyez donc la
quantité totale d'énergie mobilisée par
alors j'allais dire par l'humanité non
en fait par les machines domestiquées
par l'humanité depuis un siècle et demi
ce que vous voyez c'est que à l'échelle
mondiale toutes les énergies se sont
empilées les unes sur les autres le
charbon est venu par-dessus le bois on n
jamais consommé autant de charbon dans
le monde que cette année le pétrole est
venu par-dessus le charbon et on est
proche du maximum on y est plus mais on
est proche du maximum le gaz est venu
par-dessus le pétrole et cetera
l'énergie nucléaire cher à votre mère
est venu en haut là vous voyez en et les
les énergies renouvelables cher à votre
mère aussi sont venus en haut là en
rousse alors évidemment on va beaucoup
parler dans le journal des énergies
nucléaires qui m'ont précédé dans la
presse ici du reste et des énergies
renouvelables mais je vous rappelle que
ce qu'il y a dans le journal n'engage
que le journal et qu'il n'y a pas de
lien entre la pagination dans le journal
et l'importance réelle dans le monde
d'accord c'est deux processus
indépendants l'un de l'autre euh ce qui
est important par exemple c'est
important tous les jours de respirer le
journal ne vous parle pas tous les jours
de respirer donc les processus
importants et les processus dans le
journal c'est deux ensembles qui peuvent
être parfaitement
disjoints la réalité énergétique
d'aujourd'hui c'est que le monde est
dopé à l'énergie fossile il ne l'a
jamais été autant et en fait 80 % de
l'approvisionnement mondial est fossile
aujourd'hui 80 % de l'approvisionnement
mondial était déjà fossile quand j'avais
5 ans c'est quiétait il y a très très
longtemps donc vous voyez que en fait
l'énergie fossile elle est restée
dominante depuis maintenant quasiment 60
ans dans le
monde alors on aurait pu face à cette
réalité physique avoir une grille de
lecture du monde qui nous permett de
nous en rendre compte qu'aujourd'hui
vous vous en rendez pas compte et vous
allez comprendre pourquoi euh et c'est
pas ça qu'on a fait alors pour ça je
vais vous citer deux personnages un peu
anciens le premier il s'appelle Charles
Dupain vous en avez jamais entendu
parler je pense pas euh c'était un
polytechnicien donc vous auriez quand
même du non pardon euh qui il y a deux
siècle s'est posé la question suivante
il s'est dit la population anglaise et
la population française sont à peu près
de la même taille et la production
anglaise et le triple de celle de la
France est-ce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre il va falloir que j'arrive à
comprendre ça alors il s'est dit quand
même il y a d'autres forces vivantes qui
concourent à la production il y a par
exemple les chevaux de traai d'accord et
cetera
alors il a amélioré un peu son calcul et
il a constaté que si on rajoutait ce
qu'on appelle les autres forces vivantes
d'accord et puis qu'on modulait la
population alors je suis désolé pour les
dames qui sont dans cette salle mais il
avait compté les femmes pour les hommes
pour un les femmes pour un demi et les
enfants pour un/art à l'époque il y
avait pas vraiment l'école et les
enfants étaient au travaux des champs
comme tout le monde donc il fait son
calcul et puis il dit quand même je
tombe sur des ordres de grandeur à peu
près voisin et puis il se dit en fait ça
suffit pas parce que je me rends compte
que en Grande-Bretagne comme en France
il y a également ce qu'il a appelé des
forces inanimées qui participent à la
production les moulins avant à eut les
bateaux il y avait déjà une marine
marchande extrêmement importante et et
surtout vous voyez à la dernière ligne
les machines à vapeur qui avaient pris
leur ressort en Grande-Bretagne bien
avant la France et à ce moment Charles
Dupin constate que si on rajoute les
forces inanimées aux forces vives on
obtient une force totale industrielle
qui est de l'ordre du triple en
Grande-Bretagne de ce qu'elle était en
France CQFD ça explique pourquoi la
production industrielle était trois fois
plus importante pourquoi est-ce que la
Chine a eu pendant un temps un PIB
inférieur à celui de la France tout
simplement parce que pendant un temps la
Chine a eu moins de machines que la
France point puis quand la Chine s'est
mise à avoir plein de machines son PIB a
dépassé celui de la France celui de
l'Allemagne celui du Japon enfin voilà
c'est une affaire de machine à l'époque
on aurait pu avoir une comptabilité
économique qui s'appelle qui qui
reposait sur les kilwh qu on aurait pu
se dire la production c'est de la
transformation la transformation c'est
de l'énergie je par sous le contrôle du
physicien et donc on va tout compter en
kilwh ça va être ça notre unité de
compte de la production c'est pas du
tout ça qu'on a fait on a décidé de
faire appel à des économistes qui nous
ont dit on va tout compter en monnaie et
du coup maintenant on a une illusion
d'optique qui est que notre système
productif il est totalement détaché de
la physique et il ne dépend que de
paramètres économiqu si vous mettez dans
votre système productif des gens qui
travaillent et du capital en sortie le
supermarché sera plein c'est ça la
théorie économique dans les fonctions de
production vous avez du capital du
travail et puis vous avez une espèce de
de miracle qui s'appelle le progrès
technologique on sait pas trop ce
queouvre et en fait le progrès
technologique c'est tout bêtement
l'énergie et la physique si vous confier
un ingénieur ou un physicien le soin de
vous faire un diagramme de flux sur
l'économie qu'est-ce qu'il va vous dire
il va vous dire les atomes qui sont dans
les objets à droite là j'ai besoin de
les avoir trouvé quelque
part donc besoin d'un truc qui s'appelle
des ressources naturelles qui sont tout
simplement mes atomes arrangés autrement
et que je vais transformer parce que
comme je suis paresseux j'ai envie d'une
cuillère pour manger ma soupe c'est plus
facile que de la laper et c'est je vais
passer du mineret de fer à la cuillère
en prenant les atomes de fer qui sont
dans le mineret et en changeant la façon
dont je les arrange et puis c'est pareil
pour vos cravates vos vestes les
fauteuils sur lesquels vous êtes assis
l'excellente BD qu'on vous a montré tout
à l'heure le micro dans lequel je parle
tout ça c'est des atomes qu'on est allé
prendre dans la nature ça s'appelle des
ressources naturelles et on les a
transformé pour faire autre chose même
dans les services vous avez besoin de ça
vous ne faites pas un service
d'enseignement aujourd'hui sans mettre
les élèves à l'abri de la pluie l'hiver
ça s'appelle un bâtiment sans mettre des
fauteuils sur lesquels vous les asseyez
il a bien fallu les fabriquer sans leur
demander de venir à l'université le
matin pour ça il faut des moyens de
transport ou il faut des routes sur
lesquelles les gens se déplacent enfin
bref même pour des services vous avez
besoin de ressources naturelles et il
faut avoir une capacité de
transformation qu'on appelle le travail
et le travail en fait il est fait pour
une petite partie par nous et pour une
partie dominante par les machines y
compris pour les objets que vous allez
pouvoir trouver en
Suisse le capital n'est pas représenté
sur ce diagramme parce qu'en fait le
capital c'est juste une partie des
ressources naturelles transformées qui
que vous allez pouvoir réutiliser au fil
du temps par exemple cet immeuble est un
objet de capital parce qu'il se détruit
pas quand on s'en sert normalement il ne
s'autétruit pas à la fin de cette
conférence enfin j'espère sinon j'espère
que vous avez une bonne police
d'assurance mais normalement c'est ça le
capital c'est des ressources naturelles
transformées qui vont pouvoir servir
longtemps qui vont pas se détruire quand
on s'en sert ça se fait exactement comme
une paire de chaussettes ou une carotte
par alors dans ce diagramme vous
comprenez un certain nombre de choses la
première chose que vous comprenez c'est
que si on doit un jour avoir beaucoup
moins d'énergie on aura une capacité de
transformation qui va beaucoup baisser
et donc la production va
baisser c'est très simple beaucoup moins
d'énergie c'est beaucoup moins de
production quelle que soit la nature de
l'énergie et beaucoup moins de
ressources c'est beaucoup moins de
production aussi d'accord c'est très
simple c'est extrêmement simple et on ne
se rend pas compte de la baisse ou de la
hausse de la quantité physique d'énergie
ou de ressources que nous avons parce
que nous avons décidé de tout regarder
avec une convention humaine qui
s'appelle de l'argent l'argent je vous
le rappelle ne paye que des
individus le prix d'un objet c'est juste
un empilement de salaire et de rente en
Suisse comme en France qui ont pris
place entre le moment on est parti des
ressources naturelles parfaitement
gratuites et on est arrivé à la fin à
l'objet manufacturé parfaitement payant
d'accord entre les deux vous n'avez que
des revenus humain vous n'avez pas de
dotation aux amortissements pour
diminution des stocks de ressources
naturelles vous n'avez pas de provision
pour risque parce que on commence à
faire à causer des gros problèmes dans
l'environnement tout ça n'existe
pas alors pour le moment ça marche très
bien cette affaire là vous avez ici un
graphique qui vous donne pour le monde
dans son ensemble mais en fait ça
vaudrait également pour l'économie
suisse pourquoi parce que l'économie
suisse est terriblement cont tributaire
de la mondialisation si je coupais les
frontières de la Suisse aujourd'hui et
que j'empêchais tout import tout export
le PIB suisse serait probablement divisé
par 5 à 10 vous mangeriez ce qui ce qui
les vaches des alpages et ce qui pousse
dans la dans la
plaine du du lac de nos Châtel là pointb
ça ferait pas beaucoup hein je peux vous
assurer euh quand vous allez à la COP ou
ou à migroos et que vous regardez made
in pour les produits agricolesin c'est
pas pas beaucoup made in Switzerland
mais même si on fait de la pub pour le
Suisse à la télé
euh donc en fait la la la Suisse
évidemment s'il y avait pas la
mondialisation il y aurait pas les
banques suisses il y aurait pas les
avocats fiscalistes suisses il y aurait
pas nestley il y aurait pas Vitol Vitol
il y aurait pas Glencore enfin tous ces
trucsl n'existeraient pas d'accord donc
en fait une Suisse
démondialisée c'est une Suisse dont le
PIB est divisé par n'importe quoi entre
5 et 10 donc en fait le PIB mondial
c'est intéressant à avoir en tête y
compris pour l'économie suisse parce que
la Suisse en dépend au premier ord la
France aussi hein mais la Suisse en pas
au premier ordre alors ce que vous voyez
sur ce graphique c'est que entre 1965 et
2022 si on regarde pour chaque année
quelle est la quantité d'énergie qui a
été utilisée dans le monde c'est-à-dire
en fait le parc de machines en service
et de l'autre côté quel est le PIB
mondial bah vous avez une Casie droite
dis autrement dis-moi combien d'énergie
tu donnes à manger aux machines aux
machines mondiales je te dirai quelle
est la production économique mondiale et
donc la quantité d'argent puisque c'est
une fration du PIB n'est-ce pas que je
peux consacrer cré aux
universités c'est aussi simple que ça
donc l'Université de Genève comme les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
français he il y a pas de différence
dépend au premier ordre de cette
courbe alors évidemment vous allez me
dire non non c'est pas vrai la Suisse
nous on est moins carboné que les autres
effectivement vous êtes moins carbonés
que les autres là vous avez une
représentation de la quantité d'énergie
qui est consommée par les machines
situées en Suisse là il s'agit de la
consommation Suisse donc les machines
situées en Suisse depuis 1965 alors tout
en haut en bleu là vous voyez
l'hydroélectricité et vous voyez que cet
approvisionnement il est pas constant
mais il est très faiblement croissant ce
qui veut dire que en fait l'essentiel
des sites équipables ont été équipés
hein pour les grands barrages en dessous
en jaune vous avez le nucléaire euh
allez ça fait la troisème fois que je
prononce le mot ce soir pas sûr que je
vais le prononcer une 4è en dessous en
vert vous avez le gaz et enfin en bas
vous avez le pétrole qui alimente toutes
les très modestes voitures Mercedes BMW
Audi et cetera qu'on peut voir sur les
autoroutes
suisses alors vous allez me dire la
Suisse nous on sait des matérialisé vous
voyez parce que on est passé par un
maximum sur l'énergie consommée dans les
années 2000 le PIB n'arrête pas
d'augmenter alors oui il arrête pas
d'augmenter le PIB parce que c'est un
effet de la
mondialisation qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en Suisse comme en France voilà le monde
que nous avons créé nous avons créé un
monde de machine qui pour une bonne
partie d'entre elles et encore plus
deain grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle traaille toute seule
d'accord donc il y a besoin de moins en
moins de gens pour les faire bosser et
nous avons créé une armée d'employés de
bureau dans laquelle il y a les
consultants inutiles comme moi les
chercheurs utiles comme ceux qui sont
dans cette salle euh plus tous les
employés de la Ville de Genève plus tous
les gens qui travaillent dans
l'assurance maladie plus tous les gens
qui travaillent dans les banques plus
tous les gens qui travaillent je suis
sûr qu'il y en a plus que les employés
de la Ville de Genève plus tous les gens
qui travaillent chez les avocats plus
tous les gens qui voilà tous les
tous les ça plus les coiffeurs plus et
cetera donc tous les gens des services
en fait ce que nous avons créé c'est une
énorme Métropolis autonome faite de
machine ou avec très peu de gens pour la
faire avancer et pour partie situé à
l'étranger maintenant hors de Suisse en
Chine en Inde et ce sur laquelle nous
avons bâti une armée d'employés de
bureau qui sortent le soir avec le P du
pantalon ou le P de la jupe impeccable
et qui se disent du coup nous avons des
emplois
dématérialisés dématérialisés rien du
tout en fait dans les pays qui ne
consomment pas beaucoup d'énergie vous
n'avez pas d'armé d'employés de
bureau si vous allez au Kenya au
Zimbabwe vous avez pas d'armée
d'employés de bureau ça n'existe pas les
armées d'employés de bureau c'est une
création de l'énergie abondante en
Suisse comme en
France voilà donc en fait c'est ça qui
s'est passé en Suisse comme en France
nous avons cré vous vous avez nous avons
collectivement créé une civilisation
tertière riche parce qu'elle est assise
sur des flux physiques qui prennent
place ailleurs et en ce qui concerne la
Suisse il y en a beaucoup beaucoup qui
prennent place ailleurs alors là c'est
un peu taquin de ma part c'est délibéré
euh vous voyez que il y a encore 10 ans
maintenant vous êtes vous êtes en train
d'être battu par Singapour mauvaise
nouvelle euh c'est peut-être la fin du
secret bancaire je ne sais pas euh mais
vous voyez que il y a encore 10 à 15 ans
vous aviez 40 % des placements offshock
40 à 50 % des placements offshore dans
le monde ça veut dire que tous les gens
qui voulaient échapper à leur fisque
local crac il venaient euh ici euh c'est
grâce à ça que il y a des armées
d'avocats de fiscalistes et de banquiers
qui se sont développés alors il y a pas
que ça évidemment ça c'est la version
c'est la partie un peu taquine que je
vous propose mais je vous l'ai dit par
ailleurs Vitol qui est le premier
négociant en carburant au monde qui fait
les bonnes années 300 milliards de
francs de chiff d'affaires et bien les
bateaux les pétrolers et les puits de
pétrole sont en dehors de Suisse par
contre le PIB correspondant il est pour
parti en Suisse je pourrais vous faire
exactement la même chanson avec glenc je
pourrais vous faire exactement la même
chanson avec tout un tas d'autres
activités pour laquelle sans les flux
physiques qui prennent place en dehors
de Suisse la valeur ajoutée en Suisse
n'existe pas sans les mines d'or qui
sont pas en Suisse il y a pas Rolex et
cetera et cetera donc en fait la Suisse
comme la France hein mais la Suisse
encore plus quelque part que la France
elle a totalement décorréler son PIB des
flux physiques parce que l'essentiel des
flux physiques qui permettent le PIB
suisse prenne place en dehors de Suisse
et c'est pour ça que quand on parlera
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
vous diraiis que c'est pas celles qui
prennent place en Suisse qui ont de
l'importance c'est celles qui prennent
place en Suisse et en dehors de Suisse
et qui vous permettent d'avoir comme moi
du reste le niveau de vie que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
important alors la Suisse a également
bénéficié de cette évolution qui
s'appelle la
mondialisation ici vous avez alors pour
ceux qui ont des bons yeux sinon vous
demandez les jumelles de votre voisin
tout en bas là en pointillé sur cette
courbe vous avez le tonnage de la marine
marchande à voile dans le monde alors
vous l'avez à partir de 1900 vous voyez
ça doit faire 100 millions de tonnes
mais un peu avant c'était quand même
plus important les Clippers au milieu du
19e siècle il en avait quand même
beaucoup plus et la marine marchande
tant qu'elle était à voile elle pouvait
elle avait une capacité d'emport pour la
totalité de la marine marchande mondiale
de l'ordre de 20 30 40 millions de
tonnes la marine marchande moderne elle
a 2 milliards de tonnes de capacité
d'emport sans marine marchande il y a
pas de
mondialisation sans marine marchande il
y a pas de mondialisation et sans camion
il y a pas de mondialisation non plus du
reste la mondialisation c'est des
camions et c'est des bateaux
c'est-à-dire du pétrole et ainsi c'est
ce qui sera le plus difficile à
décarboner parce que autant vous pouvez
décarboner la mobilité des personnes en
passant des voitures à pétrole au vélo
électrique plus au train plus à
l'autocar plus à quelques voitures
électriques autant le porteconeneur qui
fait 10000 km pour les décarboner il y a
que deux solutions des agrocarburant en
quantité massive en affamant une partie
des gens ou bien des réacteurs
nucléaires vous avec ces deux solutions
là la la marine à voile ne ferapp pas 2
milliards de tonnes de de de capacité
d'emport dans le monde jamais hein voilà
donc ça c'est du pétrole la Suisse en a
profité parce que la Suisse est inscrite
dans une économie mondialisée la Suisse
est également inscrite dans une économie
digitalisée sans l'économie digitalisée
il n'y aurait pas de prix pour
l'intelligence artificielle du reste il
y aurait pas de chercheurs il y aurait
pas de consultants ce qui ferait deux
populations en moins à
nourrir vous avez
ici la quantité de métaux utilisé par
l'économie mondiale en fonction des
siècles vous voyez en 1700 1800 1900
2000 alors je vais m'arrêter en 1800 en
1800 la totalité de l'économie mondiale
qui à l'époque est pas du tout
mondialisée il y a quelques une fraction
de pourcent de l'économie qui fait
l'objet d'échange les soiries les
pierres précieuses les épices l'or enfin
voilà pas grand-chose mais enfin pas le
blé pas les carottes pas les poulets et
pas les vêtements et bien vous voyez
elle repose sur neuf métaux c'est pas
beaucoup ne9f méteaux plus l'or et
l'argent qui sont pas là-dessus neuf
métau et en fait ces neuf métaux sont
disponibles à peu près partout
localement en Suisse je suis sûr qu'à
l'époque vous avez quelques bas
fourneaux avec qui sont capables de
faire du fer il y en avait des centaines
en France à l'époque vous avez il y a
une vieille mine de cuivre abandonné
dans le val d'Anivier pour ceux qui
connaissent et cetera dans les montagnes
parce que les montagnes avaient fait de
la surrection donc avait mis à l'air
libre quelque part des filons qui avant
étaient en foui et donc ça permettait
d'avoir une petite activité minière
aujourd'hui la totalité des éléments du
tableau de mandelf ont une application
industrielle alors je vais en prendre un
qui m'amuse beaucoup qui est l'hélium
l'hélium il sert à faire des lasers de
la bonne longueur d'onde pour graver les
semiconducteurs est-ce que vous savez
d'où vient l'hélium dans le
monde on le cherche pas dans l'air hein
je peux vous assurer tout de suite c'est
un gaz rare il est chimiquement inerte
et c'est pas comme ça il vient des
gisements de gaz naturel figurez-vous
plus d'énergie fossile plus d'hélium
plus d'hélium plus de semiconducteur ah
merde comment est-ce qu'on fait ça c'est
pour votre mère un Réau 100 % ENR qui
demande des siconducteurs partout sans
non je vous
taquine bakine mais pas que en fait on a
créé une économie dans laquelle tout est
imriqué dans tout c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui d'abord on ne sait pas
désimbriquer les énergies on fait une
éolienne avec du charbon et on ne sait
pas désimbriquer les éléments on fait de
la mine de cuivre avec de l'hélium qui
permet de faire les semiconducteurs qui
permettent d'actionner les engins de
mine et de piloter la société qui fait
l'extraction miniaère d'accord donc tout
est dans tout il n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui de désimbriquer et on a fait
une société terriblement complexe avec
tous les éléments encore une fois du
tableau de mandalf qui on une
application industrielle et ça ça a fait
la Suisse moderne comme ça a fait la
France moderne d'accord c'est exactement
de la même manière donc en fait
l'histoire des 19e et des 20e siècles
dans tous les pays qui ont touché et
ceux qui on qui en ont bénéficié c'est
l'histoire de l'exploitation des
combustibles fossiles qui sont
parfaitement gratuits puisque comme
toutes les ressources naturelles c'est
gratuit hein on n pas payé un centime
pour l'existence des combustible fossil
et euh quand vous avez payé monsieur
Latsis dans l'ancien temps pardon il
faut des taquineries pour tout le monde
euh en fait ce que vous avez payé à
Monsieur Latsis c'est le travail et le
fait qu'il était assis au bon endroit
c'est pas du tout l'existence du pétrole
qui elle est arrivée gratuitement
d'accord c'est gratuit le pétrole comme
l'air comme le vent comme le Servin et
comme le rô tout ça c'est gratuit
d'accord le pétrole est gratuit ce qui
coûte c'est d'aller le chercher le
pétrole comme le gaz comme le charbon
brûle ça a mis en route la machinerie
mondiale qui a permis de faire les
milliards d'objets qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui ça a totalement déformé la
structure
de la société les machines bossent pour
nous on a du temps libre on travaille
moins deux fois moins en France
aujourd'hui qu' a un siècle dans l'année
on a le temps de faire des études à
l'Université de Genève si on a si on est
bien inspiré ailleurs si on est moins
bien on a le temps d'avoir des retraites
parce que la production des machines est
tellement abondante qu'on peut nourrir
vêtir loger à la fois les gens qui sont
dit avoir un travail et les gens qui
sont dit ne pas en avoir il y avait pas
de retraite il y a de siècles ça
n'existait pas on a fait la mobilité
long on a fait le tourisme on a fait la
civilisation des loisirs on a fait la
santé comment est-ce que vous voulez
consacrer 10 % du PIB à la santé quand
le PIB est
nul fait la santé et cetera et cetera et
comme les emplois tercières c'est plus
efficace quand on met les gens au même
endroit on a fait les villes les villes
étaient ridicules il y a quelques
siècles tout simplement parce que dans
dans les villes il faut nourrir les
habitants c'est la première première des
fonctions vitales et il y a de siècles
vous pourriez vous pouviez faire des
villes qui étaient limité par le surplus
agricole
d'une zone accessible à quelques jours
de transport avec les moyens de l'époque
c'était ça la taille qui était
dimensionnant pour la taille d'une ville
he saufra réim exception Rome dans
l'Antiquité et un tout petit peu Paris
au début du 2è millénaire mais bon sinon
c'était ça et donc les villes faisaient
des milliers d'habitants l'utes faisait
5000 habitants je sais pas quelle était
la taille de Genève il y a 3 siècles
mais à mon avis c'était un peu plus
petit qu'aujourd'hui exactement pour la
même raison alors vous aviez encore une
fois quelques exceptions notamment pour
les villes en borddefleuve qui laquelle
vous pouviez avoir du du transport de
masse de nourriture arrivant par le
fleuve euh mais c'était des
exceptions et nous avons pris l'habitude
de regarder tout ça sous l'angle
économique en oubliant la physique alors
je vais vous parler maintenant très
rapidement dans le faible temps qui me
reste euh un peu du changement
climatique un peu de l'approvisionnement
en combustible fossile et je ne vous
parlerai pas des ressources minérales
parce que j'aurai pas le temps et sinon
votre recteur va me faire les gros yeux
je vais commencer par parler du
changement climatique alors ici vous
avez un un un une coupure de presse
publié au pays des hobbites la
Nouvelle-Zélande les néozélandais comme
vous le savez ont les pieds plats et
poilus donc au pays des
Hobbit en
1912 1912 je suis désolé s'il y a des
néozélandais dans la salle et puis
j'espère qu'ils sont pas trop barqués en
général ils le sont parce que sinon ils
vont en vouloir un peu mais c'est pas
vraiment l'épicentre de la science
mondiale et bien ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'en
1912 non pas vraiment en 1912 en Nou
nouelle Zélande on entre guillemets sait
ce qu'est le changement climatique on le
sait on sait que le CO2 mis dans
l'atmosphère crée un effet de couverture
et on sait que l'effet pourrait être
considérable cont tenu de la combustion
qui à l'époque concerne essentiellement
le charbon qu'on fait d'accord on sait
on le sait parce que quasiment un siècle
avant Joseph Fourier cocorico publie un
article scientifique dans lequel il
caractérise l'existence d'un effet de
serre effet ser qu'il nomme ainsi après
des expériences faites par un Suisse que
vous connaissez probablement oracte
benénédict de saucur euh qui outre le
fait queil avait très envie de monter
sur le Mont Blanc s'est amusé à empiler
des boîtes en ver les unes dans les
autres et en plçant des thermomètres
dans chacune des boîtes en ver il a
constaté que plus on allait vers le
centre de son empilement de boîte et
plus la température était élevée et donc
il a appelé ça l'effet de serre en fait
c'était un effet dû à l'interception des
infrarouge parce que quand vous êtes
dans la boîte du centre l'effet
mécanique d'absence de convection de
l'air ne joue pas plus que quand vous
êtes dans la boîte à l'extérieur
et puis euh avant la fin du 19e siècle
la messe estdite euh trois physiciens
physicienne et santé arenus
caractérisent les gaz à effet de serre
et disent que si on double le CO2 dans
l'air la température planétaire monte de
4°gr donc tout ça est connu depuis plus
d'un siècle la raison pour laquelle on
s'agite pas c'est parce que c'est le
renoncement au combustible fossile qui
nous limite à cause de tout ce que j'ai
expliqué dans la première partie c'est
pas sympa de se priver d'un truc quand
on est paresseux et
accumulatif alors de quoi est-ce qu'on
est en train de parler dans cette
histoire vous avez ici une carte qui
vous représente les écosystèmes
installés en Europe en France et en
Suisse comme vous pouvez le voir et un
peu
ailleurs sur les siècles écoulés donc je
je mets de côté le changement climatique
récent à condition qu'on ne les coupe
pas pour faire des trucs essentiels
comme l'Université de Genève et des
trucs plus accessoires comme des champs
des routes et cetera ce que vous voyez
c'est que ce que nous avons en Europe en
terme d'écosystème à l'équilibre c'est
essentiellement des forêts très au nord
il fait trop sec et trop froid pour
qu'on ait des forêts on a donc de la
Tundra très à l'est il fait trop sec
pour qu'on ait des forêts on a donc de
la
STEP voici l'Europe il y a 20000 ans
alors il y a 20000 ans nous sommes au
cœur de la dernière are glaciaire
c'est-à-dire que dans les grandes
oscillations climatiques du quaterna qui
ont pris place sur les deux derniers
millions d'années nous sommes au point
le plus froid de cette oscillation
d'accord euh alors vous voyez que
l'Europe ne ressemble pas vraiment à ce
qu'elle est euh aujourd'hui d'abord il
n'y aurait pas beaucoup je sais pas s'il
y en a aujourd'hui mais d'étudiants
finlandais suédois norvégiens danois
vous étiez dans Scandinavie il y a pas
longtemps non voilà bah vous y seriez
pas allé un vol en avion économisé non
pardon
euh donc vous tous ces gens-là étaient
sous la glace vous aviez une énorme
calotte de glace posée sur euh le la
Scandinavie alors très bonne nouvelle
pour les français même si c'est pas
là-dessus qu'ils ont trébuché cette
année les Irlandais sont sous la la
glace pour ceux qui aiment le rugby les
Écossais c'est un peu moins une menace
mais ils sont sous la glace aussi voilà
les Africains du Sud malheureusement pas
on peut pas tout
avoir le Canada est également sous la
glace le nord de la Russie est également
sous la glace pour constituer ces
énormes glaçons il a bien fallu prendre
de l'eau quelque part et la nature a
opéré un énorme transfert d'eau par
précipitation enfin évaporation
précipitation sous forme de neige depuis
les océans et le niveau des océans a
baissé de 120 m
donc les avocats fiscalistes de Genève
n'ont pas de concurrents dans les
Anglo-Normandes voilà il y a pas de
paradis fiscaux dans la Manche puisqu'il
n'y a pas de manche et il n'y a pas de
brexit il y a une continuité
territoriale entre la France et la
Grande-Bretagne par contre vous voyez
qu'il y a pas beaucoup de Suisses
puisquils sont sous la glace aussi
malheureusement la vallée du Rône ben
Sion n'existe pas à la place de Sion il
y a un
glacier le climat est beaucoup plus
froid et donc beaucoup plus sec puisque
dans un climat beaucoup plus froid la
pression de vapeur saturante est
beaucoup plus basse et l'évaporation est
beaucoup plus basse et donc les
précipitations sont beaucoup plus basses
clat est beaucoup plus sec en même temps
d'être froid et ce que vous avez là où
vous n'êtes pas englacé en en Europe
c'est des écosystèmes qui ressemblent à
ce que vous avez actuellement au nord de
la Sibérie c'est-à-dire de la STEP et de
la Tundra et l'INC de l'époque me dit
que vous avez 100000 français alors je
ne sais pas combien il y a de Suisse à
l'époque or la partie qui est sous la
glace à mon avis pas
beaucoup donc ça c'est l'Europe il y a
20000 ans et puis pour passer dans at
préindustriel que vous voyez à droite
manifestement nous avons réchauffé le
climat c'est assez difficile de faire
fondre des glaçons à l'air froidissant
et bien le réchauffement climatique qui
a piloté cette transition il est de
l'ordre d'une élévation de 4°gr en 10000
ans voilà donc là vous avez le résultat
d'une expérience grandeur nature qui a
été faite par la planète consistant à
réchauffer le climat de 4°gr en 10000
ans et vous voyez le genre de
transformation de l'environnement que ça
provoque alors maintenant j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle pour notre ami chercheuse
sur les mécanismes de résolution de
conflit elle va avoir énormément de
boulot si on s'amuse à faire la même
expérience en un siècle si on s'amuse à
faire la même expérience en un siècle je
peux vous donner le résultat ça sera la
guerre partout ça sera la guerre partout
parce que l'effondrement des conditions
stables pour 8 milliards d'individus
sédentaires ira considérablement plus
vite que notre capacité à gérer ça dans
la joie et la bonne humeur
considérablement plus vite il va y avoir
une tension croissante absolument
partout une compétition croissante pour
les ressources résiduelles absolument
partout et en gros ça va être le
CH alors on peut rentrer dans le détail
pour savoir quelles sont les
conséquences en fait je le ferai pas
parce que j'ai pas le temps et de toute
façon je ne le ferai pas pour une autre
raison parce que comme nous sommes en
train de faire une expérience pour la
première fois on peut avoir des grandes
tendances mais avoir une liste précise
de ce qui peut se passer personne n'en
sait rien on peut avoir des grandes
tendances mais on a aura jamais une
liste précise et ça veut dire que à
partir de maintenant nous allons devoir
apprendre à naviguer dans le brouillard
ce qui est extrêmement désagréable et
nous allons devoir apprendre en Suisse
comme en France à adapter nos systèmes
pour qu'il soi moins performant dans la
fourchette étroite de conditions
favorables que nous avons connu depuis
quelques siècles mais beaucoup plus
résilient en cas de conditions adverses
qui ne vont pas tarder à survenir de
façon
croissante vous savez que notre
président
il y a pas très longtemps pour ses vœux
il a dit qui aurait pu prédire le
changement climatique ça a fait un peu
gloser chez nous j'espère que vous lui
jetez pas des tobat pourrie quand il
viendra dans 2 jours pour autant mais
voilà alors moi je vais vous faire trois
qui aurait pu prédire qui sont des vrais
qui auraient pu prédire parce que je
pense que pas grand monde dans cette
salle il aurait pensé il y a quelques
années qui aurait pu prédire que le
trafic du canal de Panama allait devoir
être divisé par de parce que la
sécheresse au-dessus de l'Amérique
centrale empêche le remplissage du lac
gatoun dont sont dont est tirer l'eau
douce qui permet de faire les éclusages
bah pas moi j'aurais pas pensé
spontanément je pensé aux sécheresses à
l'époque je penserai sécheresse culture
récolte mauvaise et cetera jamais
j'aurais pensé que ça allait enququider
une partie du trafic maritime mondial
jamais qui aurait pu prédire que il y
allait y avoir des vols de branches
d'olivier avec des olives
dessus en Espagne à cause du et en Grèce
à cause du réchauffement climatique je
sais pas si vous avez suivi la actualité
agricole de l'Espagne cette année mais
enfin à cause de la sécheresse
extrêmement violente qu'ils ont connu la
récolte d'olive a été divisée par deux
or il se trouve que l'Espagne fournit de
mémoire la moitié des olives de l'huile
d'olive dans le monde de telle sorte que
le prix des olives a explosé et
maintenant il y a des gens qui déboulent
avec des tronçonneuses dans les champs
d'oliviers pour embarquer des branches
avec des olives qui aurait pu prédire un
truc comme ça pas
moi qui aurait pu prédire que Acapulco
allait être victime d'un ouragan qui 12
he avant était une simple tempête
tropicale en 12h l'ouragan est passé au
stade de force 5 d'ouragan d'ouragan de
force 5 c'est du quasiment jamais vu
alors on sait quand on lit les rapports
duc excellente institution qui a son
siège pas loin d'ici que
l'intensification des ouragan est une
conséquence attendue du réchauffement
climatique à ce pointl moi j'aurais pas
imaginé
qui aurait pu prédire que en août 2022
les guides allaient refuser d'emmener
leurs clients sur le
Servin pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont refusé
parce que le Servin comme toutes les
montagnes de haute altitude c'est du
pergéisol donc c'est du sol qui est gelé
en permanence si il fait trop chaud et
étaé 2020 2022 pardon il a fait chaud de
mémoire l'isotherme zéro est resté
au-dessus de 4000 pendant un certain
nombre de jours voire de semaines et à
ce moment le pergisol commence à dégeler
et vous vous prenez des parpins sur la
figure en permanence si vous essayez de
monter sur le Servin et les Suisses ont
dit non pas cette année cette année
Onira pas alors pour le moment ça
concerne que les les guides Suisse qui
veulent pas aller sur le Servin mais
peut-être qu'un jour ça concernera les
ancrages des remontées mécaniques de
zermat par exemple
ou il y a pas de raison que je ne tape
que sur les Suisses de l'Aiguille du
Midi en France voilà alors bon vous
allez me dire ça c'est anecdotique face
au fait qu'on mange qu'on MEUR de FA et
je suis bien d'accord avec vous alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on veut pas
jou à l'expérience de manière trop
violente vous avez ici le cahier des
charges de la lutte contre le changement
climatique ce cahier des charge il est
exprimé de la manière suivante sur la
l'axe horizontale de ce graphique vous
avez la quantité totale de CO2 que les
êtres humains mettent dans l'atmosphère
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'intéresse
juste à la quantité totale parce que le
CO2 est une espèce chimiquement stable
le dioxyde de carbone comme tous les
oxydes est une espèce chimiquement
stable et une fois qu'il rentre dans
l'atmosphère tant qu'il n'est pas au
contact du sol il n'a pas de processus
d'p duration d'accord il reste là aussi
longtemps qu'il veut tant qu'il ne
revient pas au contact de l'Atmos du sol
il ne peut s'épurer que par deux
mécanisme un qui est physique c'est un
équilibrage de pression partielle entre
l'atmosphère et l'océan donc ça donne
lieu à la dissolution dans l'océan tant
qu'il y a plus de place dans l'océant
pour mettre du CO2 que dans l'atmosphère
et un deuxième processus qui est
photochimique c'est la photosynthèse
pour ça il faut un photon fux photon qui
vont fournir l'énergie nécessaire à la
dissociation de la liaison Co sans
photon il y a pas de dissociation donc
tous ceux d'entre vous qui ont essayé de
faire pousser des plantes que je ne
nommeraai pas dans un placard sans
lumière ça marche
pas donc ce que vous voyez là c'est
juste donc ce qui va compter pour le
pour le le changement climatique c'est
la quantité totale de CO2 qu'on va
mettre dans l'atmosphère d'ici à 2100
pour l'élévation de température en 200
alors à date à fin 2022 l'humanité a mis
2400 milliards de tonnes de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère en contrepartie de cette
orgie fossile que nous avons avons connu
jusqu'à maintenant et ça a réchauffé la
température planétaire de 1,2°r donc
1,2°gr effectivement vous perdez 5 à 6%
de la masse glaciaire un bon été ça va
continuer vous savez probablement que la
quasittalité des glaciers auront disparu
des Alpes en 200 ce qui va évidemment
modifier les débits des fleuves à l'aval
donc ça va vous enquitiner un peu alors
pas vous vous longtemps vous serez plus
élu euh et moi il y a longtemps que je
serai plus consultant euh mais quelques
personnes quand même
euh ça va poser des problèmes pour
l'irrigation ça va poser des problèmes
pour la navigation ça va poser enfin
voilà ça va poser tout un tas de
problèmes un peu sympathique euh
1,2°gr tous les coros pardon 15 % des
coros tropicaux sont déjà morts 1,2°gr
vous avez déjà les épicéat de pleine qui
sont condamnés en France 1,2 voilà donc
vous avez vous allez me dire vous vous
en foutez ils sont en altitude mais
quand même euh voilà donc il y a quand
même un certain nombre de choses qu'on
voit déjà 1,2°gr la moitié de la récolte
d'olive part en fumée c'est le cas de le
dire en Espagne
1,2°g vous avez la récolte céréalière
espagnole qui va également perdre plus
de la moitié 1,2°g vous avez le canal de
Panama qui s'assèche et cetera c'est
juste 1,2 deg si on veut se limiter à
1,5 alors il faut limiter les émissions
planétaires à 3000 et encore il y a des
articles scientifiques récents qui
suggèrent que c'est pas 3000 mais
2700 et à ce moment ça veut dire que
nous avons encore le droit d'émettre
d'ici à 2100 600 milliards de tonnes
pour faire de la recherche en physique
quantique du conseil en réduction des
émissions de CO2 de l'enseignement à
l'Université de Genève de la culture de
carottes des combats de renes dans le
valet et cetera tout ça 600 milliards de
tonnes de CO2 d'ici à 200
oui parce que les reines on les monte en
camion comme vous le savez probablement
pour
parti ça veut dire que d'ici à 200
l'humanité a encore le droit d'émettre
600 milliards de tonnes 2400 qui ont
déjà été émises c'est-à-dire le quart de
ce qui a été émis pendant le siècle qui
vient de s'écouler avec une humanité qui
était en moyenne de à tro fois fois
moins nombreuse ça veut dire qu'un bébé
qui naît aujourd'hui si on veut tenir
les 1,5 degr son budget carbone d'ici à
ce qu'il meurt 80 ans allez dans 77
enfin je vous le fais à 80 et bien doit
être le 10e du budget carbone de ses
grands-parents qui sont morts
aujourd'hui à 80
ans c'est ça que ça veut dire et comme
vous avez compris que les combustibles
fossiles c'est l'abondance des machines
et c'est l'abondance des objets donc
c'est notre pouvoir d'achat ça revient à
dire que d'accepter les 1,5 degrés ça
revient à dire que la génération qui
naît aujourd'hui accepte sur sa vie
d'avoir un pouvoir d'achat qui se balade
entre le 8e et le
10e le 8e avec le nucléaire le 10e non
pardon jakine jquine mais c'est à peu
près ça l'équation c'est à peu près ça
l'équation
euh de celui de ses grands-parents voilà
c'est ça les 1,5°gr alors vous comprenez
maintenant qu' y a un certain nombre de
gens qui traînent les pieds ils le
formalisent pas comme ça mais
intuitivement ils l'ont très bien
compris 2 degr on est large comme dirait
Foresti on a encore droit à 1200
milliards de tonnes pour arriver à 3600
et donc mon bébé n'a droit a droit au 5è
du pouvoir d'achat de ses grands-parents
c'est quand même vachement mieux et si
on met un Suisse et un habitant du Togo
et un français et un habitant de
Mongolie et un brésilien sur un plan
d'égalité pour un bébé qui naît
aujourd'hui en Suisse à 2 degrés c'est
pas le 5e c'est le
20e bah oui on est égalitaire ou on l'
pas donc là vous avez une petite idée du
cahier des charges si je vous le
présente de manière dynamique euh voilà
à quoi ça ressemble vous avez ici en
bleu et en vert les trajectoires
d'émission qu'il faut respecter d'ici à
2100 pour limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 ou à 2°gr vous
remarquerez que ces trajectoires elles
elles incluent la possibilité de passer
en territoire négatif c'estàdire que non
seulement il faut faudrait qu'on émette
plus 1 GAM de
CO2 mais en plus il faudrait-elle les
chadoc repomper de l'atmosphère une
partie du CO2 qu'on y a déjà mis avec
des dispositifs qui restent à inventer
et qui fonctionnent sans énergie
fossile bon alors on pourrait planter
plein de forêts mais enfin si on est 10
milliards et qu'on a besoin de croûter
c'est pas demain matin qu'on va le faire
pour le moment on fait l'inverse enfin
bon bref vous voyez c'est quand même pas
gagné d'avance et ça ça veut dire qu'en
tout état de cause d'ici à 2050 il faut
diviser les émissions planétaires par au
moins
3 alors vous avez tout un tas de
brillants mathématiciens dans cette
université qui savent que une division
par 3 en 27 ans c'est une baisse
annuelle d'à peu près 5 % si on fait une
évolution géométrique
5% par an alors je vous donneré un plan
pour Mo 5 % par an sur les deux
premières années puis après je vais vous
demander de travailler un peu parce que
j'ai pas d'idée la première année vous
faites le
covid mais vous ne remettez pas
l'économie dans l'état pré covid non non
vous laissez l'économie dans l'état post
covid d'accord la deuxème année vous
envoyez les bombardiers al pas Suiss ils
sont pas assez nombreux plutôt américain
éradiquer l'appareil industriel de
l'Allemagne et du Japon c'est ce qu'on a
fait en 1945
5 % d'émission ça c'est l'année 2 puis
l'année 3 j'ai pas d'idée donc il faut
que vous m'en donniez pour faire à
nouveau - 5 % d'émission dans
l'année donc là vous êtes en train de
comprendre ce que ça veut dire et là
c'est pour 2 degrés hein pour 1,5 c'est
- 7 par
donc vous êtes en train de comprendre
une chose c'est évident qu'on en prend
absolument pas le chemin on en prend
absolument pas le chemin et à la C 28 on
en prendra pas plus le chemin même si le
pape que j'adore va à la C
il fait des bulles sympas moi je trouve
il fait des encycliques sympas je
totalement ré mais je trouve queil fait
des encycliques sympas donc voilà donc
vous comprenez bien que que je sais que
je prends des risques en vous parlant du
pas enre protestante mais c'est pas
grave je suis ici pour faire
ça vous comprenez bien qu'on est en
train de parler de quelque chose qui est
une vraie révolution alors de temps en
temps il m'est arrivé d'utiliser cette
expression puisque vous avez compris que
le réchauffement climatique ça serait la
guerre si on veut pas la guerre il va
falloir l'économie guerre enfin c'est un
peu cet ordre là hein on va pas y
arriver juste avec des mesurettes alors
je ne dis pas qu'aujourd'hui les gens
sont pas sincères quand ils essayent
d'avancer mais vous et moi inclus on
reste dans le cosmétique aujourd'hui par
rapport à la vitesse à laquelle il faut
avancer alors nous allons parler
maintenant de la Suisse dans cette
histoire parce que quand même il faut
que je vous parle un peu de la Suisse
ici vous avez l'empreinte carbone de la
Suisse depuis 2000 merci l'Office
fédéral des statistiques euh à qui et
merci le wifi dans le train grâce auquel
j'ai obtenu ce graphique en venant ici
et voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai
maltraité les gens de la com en leur
disant que je finirai en temps réel
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que euh la
Suisse aujourd'hui a une empreinte
carbone de 112 millions de tonnes
équivalent CO2 et pour un peu moins de 9
millions d'habitants ça vous fait ton
par personne c'est quoi l'emprinte
carbone c'est la totalité des émissions
qui prennent place sur terre ou qu'ell
prennent place pour que vous puissiez
avoir ce qu'on appelle la consommation
finale que vous avez aujourd'hui
c'està-dire tous les objets qui sont
disponibles pour les
ménages lunett brosse à dents
dentifrice
vêtement nourriture véhicule
automobile chalet chalet dans les
montagnes et ce tout ça d'accord tout ce
tout ce que vous avez disponible à la
consommation finale place de cinéma
whatever smartphone ordinateur et bien
c'est toutes les émissions de gaz et
effetsr qui ont été nécessaires qu'elles
prennent place chez vous ou en dehors de
chez vous ce que vous voyez c'est qu'ell
prennent place essentiellement en dehors
de chez vous donc ce qui permet
aujourd'hui à la Suisse de vivre comme
elle vit c'est essentiellement des
machines qui travaillent pas en Suisse
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure hein ça se voit au travers de
cette empreinte carbone et c'est une
autre manière de dire que si je coupais
les imports et les exports
instantanément vous auriez les 2 tiers
qui disparaîtrai enfin vous auriez plus
une casserole ou à peu près euh plus un
vêtement plus une paire de lunettes et
cetera à quoi ressemble l'empreinte
carbone alors là je vais vous donner le
détail pour la France parce que j'ai pas
réussi à obtenir le même détail pour la
Suisse mais ça vous donne quelques idées
en gros vous avez cinq paquets à peu
près équivalents je vous montrerai après
les paquets pour la Suisse sont pas
exactement les mêmes un premier paquet
concerne les déplacements alors les
déplacements il y en a une partie qui se
fait en voiture vu la cylindrée de la
voiture Suisse moyenne je soupçonne
qu'en Suisse c'est plus élevé et vous
avez une partie qui se fait en avion
alors vous voyez que l'avion c'est non
négligeable face à la voiture et en fait
il faut voir qu'un seul vol en avion
c'est quelques tonnes de CO2 si vous
prenez un long courrier donc c'est ça
vous double votre budget carbone voiture
sur l'année si vous prenez un seul vol
long courrier pour alleer vous dépayser
les à Bali ou au
Mexique après vous avez un deuxième gros
paquet c'est les vaches des rinces non
pardon c'est la viande les produits
animaux les boissons c'est-à-dire ce que
vous mangez là-dedans vous voyez en fait
que les produits animaux et les boissons
c'est l'essentiel du gros paquet donc si
vous mangez des courgettes c'est
beaucoup moins carboné que si vous
mangez de la fondue ou de la viande
séché
euh après si vous mangez de la fondue
vous avez fatalement de la viande séchée
he on fait pas de fromage sans faire des
vaches de réforme et des veaux
euh et les boissons c'est pas
négligeable donc tous les sodas avec des
marques que je ne nommerai pas euh si je
vais quand même les nommer en France une
des premières références vendues en
grande surface c'est la bouteille de
coca et euh dans les difficultés
alimentaires qu'ont actuellement les
Français un truc très étonnant c'est que
ils Mang moins de produits sains et
continuent à acheter autant de coca et
de Nutella voilà comprennent qu'il
pourra ensuite vous avez un troisième
paquet qui est le logement alors le
logement c'est essentiellement l'énergie
du logement mais vous avez également
l'énergie nécessaire à faire tourner les
cimenteries de hsim et les aéries que
vous n'avez pas chez vous mais qui font
quand même des fers à béton qui sont
nécessaires pour la construction ensuite
vous avez les achats alors les achats
c'est le mobilier c'est vos achats de
loisirs donc les VTT pour aller dans la
montagne les skis pour aller dans la
montagne et cetera l'électronique euh
c'est les meubles c'est les vêtements
c'est et cetera et enfin vous avez les
services publics tout à fait à droite ça
c'est les F16 qui vont faire des ronds
dans l'eau enfin des ronds dans l'air
pardon a-dessus du Val d'Anivier de
temps en temps en faisant un bouquin de
tous les diables euh plus les
établissements d'enseignement donc
typiquement les émissions de cet
établissement ici sont dans la barre
service public si je fais l'empreunte
carbone de la Suisse donc là vous avez
pour la France c'était juste pour vous
détailler et maintenant je vous fais une
petite comparaison franco-suisse
qui gagne c'est vous la France est à 10
tonnes vous à 13 vous gagnez je
m'incline voilà alors vous voyez que
pour les déplacements la Suisse est
a-udessus de la France grosse voiture
plus d'avion pour l'alimentation vous
êtes en dessous et alors ça je pense que
c'est attribuable au fait que la viande
ça coûte un bras ici alors que c'est le
cas c'est le cas de le dire une épaule
de
mouton donc il y a probablement ça qui
qui je va pas regardé le détail je me
loge c'est c'est à peu près équivalent
parce que vous avez quand même beaucoup
d'habitations ici qui sont chauffées au
fouel en particulier les habitations qui
sont hors réseau alors là les salaires
se traduisent en achat et donc j'achète
la Bar est quasiment deux fois plus
haute voilà parce que vous acheter deux
fois plus d'électronique de vêtements de
montre Rolex non pardon j'ai rien dit et
cetera et cetera et ça c'est juste la
conséquence de votre pouvoir d'achat
voilà si vous vouliez pas avoir une
barre très haute une partie de l'argent
vous gagnez il faudrait le brûler comme
ginbourg d'accord
une caméra de télé vous brûlez le pognon
et là c'est bon la barre baisse et enfin
vous voyez également une barre plus
haute pour les services publics que là
je ne m'explique pas je sais pas
peut-être que les hôpitaux je ne vois
sont mieux chauffés que les hôpitaux
français en faud je ça j'ai pas
l'explication mais mais vous voyez j'ai
pas fini le titre en plus mais vous vous
voyez que le l'empreinte carbone d'un
suisse elle est plus élevée que
l'emprinte carbone d'un français et elle
est plus élevé que la moyenne européenne
de mémoire alors même que votre
électricité est totalement décarbonée et
ça c'est la conséquence encore une fois
des du mode de vie alors si on se dit
quand même le mode de vie Suisse il est
sympa de fait il est
sympa je pense pas qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui se plaignent d'habiter à
Lausanne par exemple Genève je sais pas
mais Lausanne c'est quand même sympa
Genève il se plign oui il se plent
nécessrement vous voyez que cux de toute
façon les gens qui se plent qui viennent
vous voir ça c'est une des grands des
grands charmes de la fonction
d'élu donc on pourrait se dire bah tout
ça c'est sympa on a aucune envie de
diminuer alors malheureusement il y a
une voiture Balet euh il y a une voiture
Balet qui arrive qui est que les
combustibles fossiles sont pas éternels
en fait pour faire des combustible
fossile il faut des micro-organismes
ayant vécu il y a très très longtemps
dans l'eau essentiellement dans l'océan
et qui derrière par le biais de la
tectonique des plaques voit les restes
enfouit sous terre chauffé par la
géothermie compressé par la pression
terrestre et ça fait une land pyrolyse
qui finit par vous transformer ça
exactement comme la distillation dans un
alombique euh en non c'est pas tout à
fait le même principe mais en
combustible fossile c'est-à-dire gaz
pétrole charbon le charbon il reste dans
des petites inclusions et le gaz et le
pétrole peuvent éventuellement circuler
dans la croûte terrestre alors c'est un
processus qui prend de bout en bout
n'importe quoi entre quelques dizaines
de millions et quelques centaines de
millions
d'années donc le métier de Monsieur
latsisper il n'est pas perpétuable à
l'infini c'est pas possible parce que
avec des combustibles fossiles qui sont
donnés en quantité donné une fois pour
toutes vu le temps de formation et bien
les mathématiques vous interdisent
d'avoir une extraction qui soit
indéfiniment croissante voire même
indéfiniment constante vous êtes obligé
d'avoir un maximum alors en ce qui
concerne le pétrole dit conventionnel
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui n'est pas les
sables bitumineux du Canada et le
pétrole de chiste j'ai fini dans 2
minutes et le pétrole de
chiste américain le maximum a été passé
en 2008 ce rapport qui aurait dû faire
les gros titres des journaux télévisé un
mois de suite et passé complètement sous
le radar et en général quand je demande
dans une Assem assemblée représentative
là vous êtes pas représentatif puisque
sont venus les gens qui avaient envie
mais dans une assemblée représentative
qui a entendu parler de ce trucl si j'ai
une main et demie qui se lève c'est le
bout du
monde ça dit quand même quelque chose de
très important en fait c'est le passage
du pic de production conventionnel en
2008 qui explique probablement la crise
des subprimes qui explique probablement
le fait que l'économie est légèrement
commencé à se démondialiser depuis cette
époque qui explique que la production
industrielle européenne n'est pas
repartie à la hausse si je tire un trait
entre 2007 et 2022 et cetera et cetera
donc c'est quand même un un un sujet qui
a une petite importance et dont à peu
près personne n'a parlé au CHI project
on a demandé à se projeter plus loin
pour l'approvisionnement européen alors
je suis désolé on a fait de
l'ostracisement antisuisse c'est l'Union
européenne qui nous intéressait vous
aviez qu'àêtre dedans donc on a regardé
pour les 16 on a regardé pour les 16
premiers fournisseurs de pétrol de
l'Union européenne mais enfin la Suisse
en dépend parce que vous êtes connecté
par pipeline essentiellement aux
terminaux pétroliers européen vous avez
pas de peu de pétroliers qui remontent
le rô jusqu'au lac lément pour décharger
leur cargaison sur le lac lément en tout
cas j'en ai pas vu souvent donc ça vous
concerne directement aussi donc on a
pris par la Manche trois personnes qui
étaient respectivement l'ancien patron
de l'exploration de Total l'ancien
patron de l'évaluation des gisement de
chez Total et un ancien analyste pétrole
et gaz de la on leur a mis entre les
mains une base de données que Monsieur
lsis connait bien qui est géré par
restad energy et qui fait l'inventaire
de l'ensemble des gisements pétroliers
dans le me et on a demandé à ces trois
personnes de nous faire un pronostic
pour les 16 premiers fournisseurs de
l'Europe qui sont aussi les 16 premiers
producteurs de pétrole dans le monde
hors Brésil et Canada quel était leur
pronostic sur la production future de
ces états sous seule contrainte
géologique donc là on dit il y a pas de
politique climat on s'en fout du climat
juste on regarde ce qui peut sortir de
terre contte tenu du fait que le pétrole
met 300 millions d'années à se former ou
50 juste ça et voilà le résultat de leur
calcul ou de leur évaluation ce qu' nous
disent c'est d'ici à 2050 les 16
premiers fournisseurs de l'Europe vont
voir leur production divisé par de vous
allez dire peut-être qu'ailleurs ça va
augmenter non non ailleurs ça va suivre
à peu près la même évolution ce qui veut
dire que leurs exportations vers
l'Europe puisque les producteurs vont
commencer par garder le pétrole pour
leur propre
population leurs exportations vers
l'Europe vont t divisé par n'importe
quoi entre 2 et
20 n'importe quoi entre 2 et 20 donc je
peux vous dire que même si on s'en fout
du climat on a quand même intérêt à
s'occup un tout petit peu de la question
de la décarbonation et en particulier de
la dépétrolisation du monde et je vous
rappelle que la dépétrolisation du monde
c'est sa
démondialisation à cause des bateaux et
des camions et c'est de la sobriété
matérielle choisi à ce moment on appelle
ça de la sobriété subi on appelle ça de
la
pauvreté et si dans ce contexte certains
pays Contin continu à s'enrichir ça sera
juste un transfert de richesse au
détriment d'autres qui s'appauvriront
encore plus vite et ça augmentera les
risques de conflit même si on est
nutre même si on est
[Applaudissements]
nutre c'est pas juste une taquinerie le
le il y a il y a pas de limite aux
Folies qu'on est capable de faire en cas
de désespoir c'est juste ça que je
rappelle hein en ce qui concerne le gaz
même motif même punition le pic mondial
en ce qui du gaz il est attendu pour les
années 30 give or Tak some et ce que
vous voyez sur ce graphique un truc qui
même moi m'a surpris c'est que le gaz
conventionnel donc si on exclut le Shil
gaz des Américains en fait il est sur un
plateau depuis 2010 moi je savais pas
j'ai découvert ça avec cette
analyse voilà et j'ai encore un peu de
temps pour les question vu que mon train
est demain matin non après je sais
[Applaudissements]
que
voilà j'imagine que vous êtes
impatient de poser les questions à notre
conférencier et sans plus attendre je
passe la parole à la salle euh vous
m'avez demandé effectivement de prendre
garde au fait que on prendra une
question d'une femme puis ensuite une
question d'un homme une question d'une
femme ensuite une question d'un homme
pour une question de parité ici on va la
respecter donc qui veut prendre la
première question on voit assez mal la
salle mais il y a des micros qui circule
dans la salle et je vous demanderai
simplement d'être très bref puisque le
temps est compté poser une question et
présenter peut-être vous très rapidement
merci beaucoup d'avance à qui puisje
donner la parole oui a une par on a
commencé par un homme il fa une femme
après donc peut-être vous monsieur je
sais pas si le micro peut-être donné
dans les premiers r
merci
bonsoir merci beaucoup je me permets de
rebondir sur une conférence je crois que
c'était une interviewerview vous avez
fait il y a quelques il y a quelques
semaines maintenant vous aviez donné une
une recommandation pour les universités
en disant qu'il fallait peut-être
orienter la
recherche et donci je vous écoute ENF je
connais déjà la réponse mais peut-être
que vous pourriez partager votre
recommandation sur où il faudrait
orienter la recherche puisque je crois
qu'on est au bon endroit pour ça
merci alors je vais continuer d'être un
peu
taquin est-ce que dans le monde tel
qu'il risque de se présenter le plus
urgent c'est de chercher le beson de
X ou bien est-ce que on a d'autres
priorités c'est évident
que on sort d'un monde facile où on
avait pas besoin de se poser cette
question c'est-à-dire qu'en gros quoi
qu'on trouve on y trouverait une
application
effectivement à peu près n'importe quoi
qu'on a cherché derrière on a pu trouver
une application lointaine ou proche mon
père était chercheur il a fait des
systèmes colouombiens à deux dimensions
demandez pas ce que c'est demandai
peut-être après j'ai jamais rien compris
donc je voyais des beau signes intégral
somm et CEA sur les papiers weekend et
c'est tout ce que j'ai
vu aujourd'hui vous comprenez que dans
un monde limité on va devoir choisir et
choisir s renoncer et je pense que
malheureusement ce choix devoir
s'appliquer à la recherche donc on va
devoir se poser la question de quelles
sont les recherches qui sont
fondamentales celles qui sont du luxe
dans un monde qui va se retrouver en
contraction de moyen alors je n'ai pas
la réponse à tout évidemment c'est
absolument pas si dans cette affaire il
est plus urgent de s'occuper des
mécanismes qui permettent d'avoir la
paix de ce qui permet d'éviter d'avoir
des cancers ou j'en sais rien ou
peut-être queon peut faire un peu moins
de recherche pour éviter d'avoir des
cancers et un peu plus pour éviter de
fumer et de manger des cochonneries
voilà bon donc on va devoir se poser ce
genre de question à l'évidence je suis
pas sûr que ça sera dramatique pour la
recherche en elle-même parce qu'en fait
le chercheur est souvent un animal
curieux en plus d'être paresseux et
accumulatif mais Don donc voilà il y je
pense que c'est pas un drame mais je
pense que effectivement il va falloir se
poser la question des priorités dans ce
secteur là comme dans d'autres et
évidemment il faut se la poser avec les
gens du secteur mais voilà il il faut se
la poser mais j'ai pas la réponse c'est
je je je par contre je pense que c'est
un chantier à ouvrir
merci donc il faud trouver maintenant
une question pour une personne la gente
féminine pour respecter les volontés de
not conférencier qui veut se lancer ça
pas être moi
malheureusement et peut-être une
question qui voil y a une main làb oui
je suis désolé mon système oblige à deux
premières questions ah non
mais ah non non ça marche pas le cahier
des charg pas été
respectéheus assez mal le fond de la
salle il est possible qu'il y ait des
gens au fond de la salle donc je vais
demander aux personnes qui ont les
micros de de pouvoir les repérer pour
nous dés vous mal on a beaucoup de
projecteurs en en pleine face voilà je
je suis une femme je peux poser la
question
voilà merci infiniment pour cette
conférence vraiment très clairire et
comme d'habitude comme on vous voit
toujours sur les vidéos sur Youtube
c'est vraiment excellent ma ma question
est quel est le bilan carbone des des
armes sur vos diapot on voit souvent
voilà manger se déplacer les avion mais
les armes les usines et l'industrie des
armes alors l'armée c'est à peu près
un/4 du de l'emprinte carbone des
services publics dans un pays comme la
France je je sais pas si c'est plus
important en Suisse et que ça explique
l'écart entre la Suisse et la France il
faudrait que je
regarde mais en gros c'est vous vous
avez à peu près c'est à peu près ça donc
c'est c'est un quart à peu près du le
plus gros morceau dans les services
publics en général c'est l'enseignement
en tout cas en France c'est
l'enseignement de très loin puisque
l'enseignement est essentiellement
public et je soupçonne qu'en Suisse
c'est pareil alors Monsieur peut-être
maintenant vous avez un gros morceau qui
est l'hôpital également en France juste
pour finir là-dessus en France l'hôpital
c'est entre 5 et 8 % de l'emprinte
carbone du pays enfin l'hôpital le
système de soins bien bonjour merci
beaucoup pour la présentation j'aurais
juste une petite question de savoir un
peu votre positionnement sur par exemple
la géoingénierie qui est un concept qui
est très très controversé mais je sais
pas comment vous vous situez là-dessus
et voilà
euh si vous êtes au sommet de la Tour
Effel prendre un parallèle très très
fancé
euh vous pouvez ne pas sauter ou vous
pouvez sauter en pensant qu'avant
d'arriver en bas vous arriverez à vous
tricoter un
parachute je considère que la
géoingénierie relève un peu de la
deuxième éventualité
euh c'est-à-dire
que pour dur que ça soit dit pour
difficile que ça soit de baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
pense que le Paris consistant à imaginer
qu'on va arriver à à à gérer les
conséquences par de la géoingénierie est
encore plus risqué alors il y a quelques
sous-compartiments sur lequel on peut
éventuellement imaginer parce que dans
la géoingénierie par exemple la
séquestration du carbone en ayant fait
pousser des arbres et en utilisant ces
arbres pour faire de l'électricité en
enfouissant le CO2 sous terre c'est mis
dans cette catégorie là bon ça ok on
peut en faire un peu si on veut on en
fera jamais des énormes paquets parce
que les arbres on va également en avoir
besoin pour refaire de la construction
quand on aura moins d'énergie fossile
pour faire du ciment et de l'acier on va
en avoir besoin pour faire un peu un peu
d'énergie quand même on va en avoir
besoin exactement on va avoir besoin des
surfaces sur lesquels poussent des
choses pour continuer à se nourrir pour
pour continuer à faire des matériaux pas
que des arbres hein du du lin du chanvre
la paille qu'est-ce que je
sais et donc cette possibilité là sera
restreinte en fait quand vous faites des
calculs d'ordre de grandeur alors les
miroirs en orbite c'est un délire
complet moi j'ai fait un calcul d'ordre
de grandeur aujourd'hui le le l'effet de
serre envoie 1 % d'énergie
supplémentaire à la surface de la Terre
c'est comme si le soleil avait augmenté
sa puissance de 1 %. si vous voulez
masquer ça par des miroirs ça veut dire
qu'il faut recouvrir 1 % du disque
apparent de la Terre par des miroirs en
orbite et quand vous regardez le poids
de matériaux que ça suppose d'envoyer en
orbite même avec des miroirs qui
seraient extrêmement légers euh quelques
dizaines ou centaines de grammes par
mètre carré vous vous rendez compte que
on est dans des nombres totalement
délirants d'accord euh donc je sais plus
combien de de de de centaines de
milliers ou de millions de tirs de fusé
ça faisait enfin truc euh donc le donc
est-ce que je donc donc je je ne crois
pas qu'on va faire des choses massives
avec de la géoingénierie après qu'on
peigne des toins en blanc pour éviter d'
d' avoir des îlos de chaleur c'est une
bonne idée mais mais ça ça reste des
trucs locaux euh ça règle pas le
problème de manière
globale voilà je vois une main se levée
ici sur ma droite merci beaucoup et
c'est une fin bonsoir euh j'ai une
question sur les certificats carbones
euh connaître votre position à savoir
est-ce que vous achetez sans mauvais jeu
de mot le fait d'encourager des projets
qui sont censés euh permettent de capter
du carbone et à contrario qui à nouveau
monétise une un le le le carbone voilà
alors si ça vous intéresse que vous avez
des
insomnies il y a sur le site de Carbon 4
une page qui s'appelle net Z0 initiative
et vous verrez c'est la proposition d'un
référentiel dans lequel on a considéré
trois compartiments pas fongibles entre
les émissions réelles qui prennent place
dont dépend une activité par exemple
carbon 4 par exemple l'Université de
Genève par exemple euh n'importe un
restaurant les émissions qu'on appelle
éviter qui sont les émissions que vous
pouvez éviter chez vos clients quand
vous leur vendez des produits ou
services qui leur permettent de baisser
leur propre empreinte carbone par
exemple vous avez un service de
réparation de vêtements vu que on avait
des vestes rapessées au coude là ça me
rappelle mon père euh bah c'est très
bien ça évite de jeter des vestes donc
euh si vous proposez ce genre de service
vous pouvez calculer les émissions
évitées par le fait qu'une partie de vos
clients n'achèteront pas des vêtement
neuf d'accord ces émissions évitées ça
c'est séparé des émissions
induites et enfin vous avez une
troisième catégorie qui est le carbone
séquestré qu'on considère comme étant
non fongible avec les émissions induites
et alors un truc que j'ai dit souvent
c'est la neutralité ou la compensation
pour moi c'est un anesthésiant mortel
parce qu'à partir du moment où dans une
entreprise vous dites j'ai compensé avec
des certificats et je suis neutre vous
avez envoyé à vos salariés le message
que vous vous êtes tiré d'affairire et
que c'est pas la peine de vous creuser
la cervelle alors que vous êtes vous
êtes tout autant dépendant des émissions
de gaz à effet de ser qu'avant donc
imaginons vous êtes chez un constructeur
de voiture à essence vous dites j'ai
acheté des crédits j'ai compensé j'ai
plus de problème bah bien évidemment
vous avez un problème parce que si
l'Europe interdit les véhicules à moteur
thermique vous avez beau avoir compensé
vous êtes quand même un tout petit peu
dans la mise donc la compensation en
fait c'est quelque chose qui n'est qui
qui est un anesthésiant ça conduit juste
à dire aux forces viv d'une entreprise
ou d'une municipalité surtout ne faites
rien le problème est déjà réglé sans
compter que quand vous regardez en plus
dans le détail les méthodes de
comptabilisation pour la séquestration
du CO2 ou des émissions évitées 9 fois
sur 10 vous avez quelque chose qui tient
pas la route hein vous avez des
conventions qui sont pas adaptées au
problème que vous êtes en train de
traiter donc c'est évidemment très bien
d'encourager des projets de
reforestation de de d'émission évité et
cetera il faut le faire mais il faut pas
que ce soit une excuse absolutoire pour
ne pas s'occuper par ailleurs de ces
émissions ite alors il y a évidemment
des cas de figure un peu si vous êtes un
fabricant de vélo de vélo électrique
votre premier problème c'est quand même
de substituer des voitures c'est c'est
pas tant de de limiter au maximum façon
vous allez pas y arriver plus vous
vendez de vélo pour éviter des voitures
plus votre empreinte carbone va
augmenter de toute façon par que vous
allez pas faire des cadres en bois et
des chaînes en Balza donc bon
mais globalement pour une entreprise
ordinaire il faut s'occuper séparément
des
trois et surtout ne pas ne pas les
rendre fongibles parce que ça vous
brouille la vision voilà et tout ça est
détaillé dans une méthode qui est en
libre accès qui s'appelle neté
initiative qui est disponible sur le
site de Carbon
4 merci beaucoup peut-être encore deux
dernières questions une ici si on peut
passer un micro qui se trouve juste à
l'allée centrale merci puis ensuite une
une femme et on on terminera par ces
deux
questions merci pour votre présentation
je crois que c'était très clair la
diminution de la consommation de
fossiles dans le futur elle est évidente
maintenant ce que j'aurais aimé avoir de
votre part c'est que partir du moment où
on diminue la consommation de fossile on
va tendance à augmenter la consommation
d'électricité parce qu'on va mettre des
pompes à chaleur on va installer des
voitures électriques les processus
industriels vont passer de du gaz à
l'énergie électrique alors comment ça se
passe ce changement entre la
décroissance de la consommation
d'énergie fossile et l'accroissement de
l'énergie électrique est-ce que vous
avez des prévisions de ou de
consommation d'énergie électrique dans
les prochaines années pour ces pour les
pays européens alors pour éviter des
fossiles vous avez deux grandes marges
de manœuvre ou trois grandes marges de
manœuvre plus exactement vous avez une
première marge qui est ce qu'on appelle
l'efficacité c'est-à-dire que vous
gardez le même service et vous rendez
simplement l'appareil plus efficace
typiquement c'est ce qu'on fait les
ingénieurs du monde automobile sur les
dernières décennies vous avez une
deuxième marge de manœuvre qui consiste
à se passer du service donc vous dites
très bien
ma voiture je l'envoie à la casse et je
prends le métro le bus le vélo le vélo
électrique la charrette à cheval ce que
vous voulez et puis vous avez une
troisième marge de manœuvre qui est de
décarboner l'énergie donc vous gardez
également un appareil qui consomme de
l'énergie mais vous décarbonez cette
énergie en fait il va falloir jouer sur
les trois tableaux en même temps et tout
est une affaire de proportion alors on a
fait des calculs assez sophistiqué pour
la France je les ai malheureusement pas
fait pour la Suisse dans un travail qui
s'appelait le plan de transformation de
l'économie française qu'on a qu'on a
mené en France où on a fait tous ces
calculs de bouclage et alors ces calculs
de bouclage ils sont on est obligé de
les faire de façon totalement
transversale je vous prends l'exemple de
la cimenterie pour décarboner la
cimenterie tout dépend de combien de
tonnes de ciment vous estimez avoir
besoin
euh alors en France actuellement on
constate que on construit deux fois plus
de logements qu'il n'y a de formation de
nouveaux ménag donc on s'est dit bah
peut-être queon pourrait construire
moins al évidemment quand on dit ça les
promoteurs nous tombent dessus les
constructeurs nous tombent dessus ça m'a
fallu quelques passes d'armes avec les
milieux d'affaires mais peu importe euh
et vous vous rendez compte qu'en fait en
France une bonne partie de la politique
de soutien au logement c'est une
politique de soutien au constructeur et
pas une politique de soutien aux
habitants
euh si on commence par diviser la
quantité de ciment qu'on produit par un
facteur 2 puis que derrière on se rend
compte en plus que la quantité de ciment
dans le béton très souvent elle est
excessive parce que on a une formulation
unique que vous fasiez un bâtiment 10
étages ou un bâtiment d'un sol donc là
vous pouvez encore gagner quelque chose
à la fin vous vous rendez compte que
l'électricité dont vous avez besoin pour
électrifier votre processus là en
l'occurrence pour le ciment c'est
compliqué parce que il y a toujours du
CO2 fatal à cause de la chimie ça on est
d'accord mais vous vous avez mais on
peut au moins électrifier le four et
bien vous vous vous rendez compte que la
quantité dont vous avez besoin n'est pas
la même selon le prérequis que vous avez
mis en entrée sur la consommation finale
de ce dont vous avez besoin c'est pareil
pour l'acier l'acier on peut réduire le
minera de fer avec de l'hydrogène la
quantité d'acier donc aujourd'hui on
fait 250 kg d'acier par personne et par
an dans le monde en moyenne 2 milliards
de tonnes d'acier bon est-ce qu'on en a
besoin d'autant oou est-ce qu'on peut se
contenter de moins alors moins c'est on
retouche à la construction on touche à
la taille des engins de transport enfin
voilà vous voyez donc en fait on est
obligé de faire ce grand bouclage donc
oui ce qui est sûr c'est que dans tous
les cas de figure la proportion de
l'énergie qui sera électrique augmente
dans un monde décarbonés parce que les
grands modes de production enfin
d'extraction d'énergie l'environnement
décbonés sont des modes électriques vous
avez les modes renouvelables d'un côté
vous extriez de la puissance mécanique
vent et eut hydroélectricitéire de la
puissance électromagnétique c'est le
solaire de la puissance chimique c'est
la biomasse hein donc c'est c'est c'est
ça vous extrayez ou bien de la puissance
nucléaire ce qui est un autre un autre
mode décarboné mais effectivement à
l'arrivver vous allez avoir
essentiellement des modes des modes
électriques et vous allez avoir un peu
de biomasse que vous allez pouvoir
utiliser directement s forme de
carburant liquide ou de gaz en étant
très sélectif sur les premiers usages
que vous allez avoir et personnellement
les les derniers biocarburants qui les
premiers biocarburants qu'on va avoir
plutôt que de les utiliser pour que les
touristes suisses ou Français puissent
continuer d'aller à Bali je pense que
c'est plus urgent de les utiliser pour
qu'on continue à avoir des
tracteurs mon avis mais quand même
dernière question de madame qui se
trouve juste au 3 4e rang sur ma droite
merci
beaucoup
et on terminera par cette dernière
question bonsoir merci beaucoup pour
votre présentation c'était passionnant
eu il me semble que dans les graphiques
que vous avez présenté à la fin ça
annonce une décroissance forcée comment
est-ce qu'on peut collectivement et
individuellement se préparer à ça en y
passant beaucoup de temps et en donnant
beaucoup de prixadsis pour des gens qui
proposent des méthodes pertinent pour
s'attaquer au problèmes non je suis très
sérieux euh aujourd'hui en économie vous
n'avez pas
quasiment pas de travail académique qui
est comment est-ce qu'on gère la société
dans un contexte dans lequel c'est pas
la croissance qu'on a mais c'est la
décroissance comment je gère les
retraites comment je gère les recettes
fiscales de l'État de Genève ou de la
Ville de Genève comment est-ce que je
gère le système éducatif comment est-ce
que je gère la répartition des revenus
tous ces trucsl personne ne ne s'y
intéresse parce que de toute façon on a
présupposé depuis le début de l'économie
classique que c'était une question qui
n'existait pas et à mon avis la boîte à
outils qui sortirait de ces réflexions
sera d'une importance cruciale pour ce
qui nous attend vraiment alors
économiquement on peut très bien
s'imaginer qu'on va avoir de la
croissance verte ça pose pas de problème
il suffit de supprimer la notion
d'inflation donc si vous supprimez
l'inflation peut avoir autant de
croissance verte qu'on veut c'est pas un
problème d'une année sur l'autre une
table vaut deux fois plus cher mais en
fait vous l'avez pas faite exactement
pareil donc c'est pas grave c'est pas de
l'inflation età vous pouvez très bien
avoir de moins en moins de tables et de
plus en plus de PIB des tables avec ce
genre de de de de convention mais la
réalité physique c'est que vous aurez
moins Mo table donc la réalité physique
c'est quand même que le pouvoir d'achat
va baisser dans le monde en moyenne à un
moment c'est déjà le cas incidemment en
France en France le revenu disponible
des ménages est à la baisse depuis
2010 et si chez vous c'est pas le cas
pardon d'êre désagréable c'est parce que
vous captez une partie de la richesse
ailleurs dans le monde de façon
croissante désolé d' désagréable c'est
la réalité de même que si les haut
revenus dont je fais partie en France
augment c'est parce que les inégalités
saccroissent c'est pas parce qu'il y a
plus d'argent pour tout le monde euh
donc la la la réflexion donc en fait il
y a il y a pas d'autres moyen de
répondre à votre question que d'imettre
beaucoup de jus de cerveau et de manière
urgente beaucoup de jus de cerveau et de
manière urgente donc c'est très
désagréable on parlait tout à l'heure de
la reconfiguration de la recherche en
économie voilà une piste évidente en
sociologie voilà une piste évidente
comment est-ce que je fais pour gérer
harmonieusement un monde avec moins
d'accord et pour éviter qu'on se tape
dessus
euh t tous ces sujetsl sont pour moi
d'importance cruciale et aujourd'hui
alors ils commence à être un peu exploré
par des institutions non académiques au
shift c'est un peu la voie qu'on a
choisi d'explorer
project mais on n'est pas une
institution académique on publie pas
dans des revues à comité de lecture on
n'existe pas enfin on existe un peu mais
oniste pas euh mais mais je pense que
c'est vraiment urgent que le monde
académique s'en empare euh et que d'une
manière générale et le monde économique
s'en ENAR c'est-à-dire si vraiment c'est
ça qui nous attend comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise et et selon vous fabriquez de
la peinture ou des des des des
arbalettes pour les remontteres
mécaniques évidemment je la réponse sera
pas la même donc chacun dans sa
chacunière doit s'emparer de ce problème
et commencer à y réfléchir une bonne
conclusion je pense pour ce débat cette
discussion cette conférence de ce soir
on a ici à l'Université de Genève dans
toutes les universités la capacité
effectivement de faire face à ces
responsabilités je vous remercie de
l'avoir mis très clairement en évidence
vous nous avez en tout cas pas
anesthésié monsieur Y je vous remercie
et je souhaite à toutes et à tous une
très bonne soirée vous donne rendezvous
au
conférence merci
[Musique]
merci